[Musique]
pourquoi ces chiffres ont résisté aussi
bien leur utilisation est lié tout
simplement à des habitudes des habitudes
culturelles
parce que où fond si on réfléchit
simplement au système de la langue c'est
à dire à la langue comme système de
communication ces chiffres sont peuvent
être considérés comme totalement inutile
puisqu'ils sont redondants par rapport à
notre numérotation à la façon de noter
les chiffres dont nous avons l'habitude
donc le leur le fait qu'il subsiste est
liée simplement des habitudes
culturelles
ce sont également des chiffres qui eux
d'une part apparaissent dans des dents
des dénominations visuel le quinze de
france les jeux vidéo nomme également
avec des chiffres romains le rappeur
différents numéros enfin leurs
différentes versions et vie par ailleurs
ils sont également utilisés dans les
données plan rédigé grant un groupe ii
etc
c'est une habitude culturelle mais c'est
aussi un système vivant
leur place est tout à fait importante
qu'en est il des chiffres par romain au
début des grands à des grandeurs des
chapitres comme ce qui a été dit ou des
dents dans les différents chapitres on
les utilise également pour le comté roi
pour quelque chose qui est quand même
très très important parce que comme cela
a été souligné
un héritage historique c'est laitages
finit finalement etc ou latin et c'est
vrai remettre en cause l'action des
chiffres romains finalement c'est s'en
prendre à notre identité c'est ça
prendra notre civilisation et c'est
remettre en cause tout ce qui fait en
effet notre socle du brel
[Musique]
débat n'a strictement aucun sens pour
prétend vouloir rendre accessible la
culture alors que finalement on ne fait
que la détruire moi ce qui me choque
c'est si vous voulez c'est que
finalement on est là dans un délitement
de notre civilisation dans un évitement
de notre culture nos danses un
délitement de notre identité moi je suis
désolé les chiffres romains
ça fait partie de notre histoire ça fait
partie de notre civilisation
regardez ce qui s'est passé en italie ça
à 100 francs sont à bout ok les italiens
qui ont pris personnellement qu'ils
n'ont pas compris comment la france est
un pays où kate a des racines qui a des
racines at il est capable aujourd'hui de
remettre en cause lisa sion notamment de
ces chiffres romains la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui comme là parce qu'il y à
des activistes idéaux elle tout
simplement s'en prendre à la langue
française et pour donner bonne
conscience il nous raconte en effet que
c'est pour rendre plus accessibles les
choses pour que ça soit beaucoup plus
inclusive mais ça finalement ce n'est
que de la sottise
en réalité si une part d'une manière
générale ce serait évidemment tout à
fait désastreux que les chiffres romains
disparaisse totalement
mais ce qui se passe ici c'est que ils
disparaissent donc d'une manière
totalement microscopique pour des
raisons de communication tout à fait
justifiée de la part de ce musée tout à
fait justifié il n'y a absolument aucun
drame
il n'y a là rien de dangereux pour les
systèmes parce que comme je les dis ce
système de numération est bien inscrit
dans nos habitudes à la fois cognitives
et culturels donc il n'est absolument
pas menacé et cet argument pour trouve
toujours de la pente glissante c'est à
dire la glissante à vous connaissez cet
argument zone c c'est à dire si on fait
une petite chose tout va tout va se
casser la figure
ben voilà c'est un argument dont on a
l'habitude maintenant et à se laisser
trop à ça
[Musique]
alors oui les langues change mais ça
n'est pas un argument pour justifier
n'importe quoi on peut remarquer que
depuis à peu près les années 1980
globalement il y à un changement de
l'attitude des êtres humains occidentaux
à l'égard de leur langue
c'est à dire que on a aujourd'hui la la
le sentiment que on peut s'approprier la
honte qu'on veut la modifier un petit
peu comme on veut et sait mais c'est un
sentiment individuel kit dont la langue
tant que si je peux me permettre cette
personnification dont la langue n'a
absolument rien à faire c'est à dire que
les encore une fois les individus ne
peuvent rien sur sur cette puissance
qu'est la langue c'est la langue qui va
trier à un moment donné historiquement
donc l'écriture moi j'assume ma position
si vous voulez c'est de laisser les gens
libres de leur choix de la façon de
s'exprimer
la vérité c'est qu'il faut dans notre
pays renforcer les fondamentaux parce
que si aujourd'hui on en vient à
supprimer les chiffres romains c'est
tout simplement parce qu'une bonne
partie de la population de l'est
maîtrise pas chaque être humain pourrait
écrire souhaite finalement ne pas
respecter les grès grammaticales ou les
règles orthographiques
on est bien là dans une destruction de
notre civilisation bientôt on verra quoi
on verra fleurir peut-être dans notre
musée pour les panneaux un langage sms
puisque après tout puisque monsieur nous
dit que finalement nous sommes libres
d'utiliser la langue comme nous
souhaitons b danse faisons en sorte
décrire comme langage sms moi je ne fais
que défendre notre culture je ne fais
que défendre notre île votre identité
notre civilisation